ces cent mille un petit pari à la série
oui bonsoir la régie dans la capacité de
te dire que jean-michel voudrait pechoux
quelqu'un de l'équipe de production mais
en plus mais en plus oui cette personne
est ici présentes non saurez-vous
retrouver de qui je parle
alors l arast sera s'arrête pour le
moment est ce que c'est un corbeau ou
est-ce qu'on a des images
alors on en a des sandales à dix on a
d'abord un indice oui d'accord
voici un indice normalement ah oui nani
c'est parti à la régie c'est la règle
poteau donc elle est originale
moi je pense que dis-je à jean michel
est ce que vous êtes en couple en ce
moment n'ont donc savoir de ré so ce
mois jean michel est ce que voulaient
voir les images
non jean-michel on va bien sûr voir ces
images car les téléspectateurs veulent
les voir
et moi aussi je les découvre en même
temps que vous vais-je être choqués
vague être délichoc et rejette granola
d'être petit écolier ou figo lui gilles
michel
oui vous souvenez de cette séquence je
pense à plusieurs personnes
regardez memories la légion
[Musique]
doc gynéco alors j'étais à dire qu'il
n'y ait si l'heureux est de trop voilà
ça l'euro et d'autre ne rouvriront le
bal l'euro est souvent le ton est ce que
julie raynaud est ici de tpm c'est la
productrice de thé paperboy là on a
envie aussi de bien général
[Applaudissements]
une
j'ai très bien compris ce qu'il a dit
ouais je sais pas jusqu'ici est une de
mes meilleures amies vous le savez et
c'est la productrice de tp est méritée
elle est très belle y ait appel très
sympathique
julie j'ai trois questions à vous poser
déjà pourquoi le re ah oui j'ai envie de
lui demander
gilles réponse alors des points c'est
une cure en fait c'est du mythe opran me
voilà tu en prends deux par jour dans un
mois tu es plus mito ya une deuxième
question du g20 julie est ce que vous si
vous n'étiez pas mon groupe est ce que
jean michel et vous parce que vous
connaissez depuis longtemps parce que
c'était mon chroniqueur est une émission
sur la télé julie votre chroniqueur est
ce que vous auriez pu vous mettre avec
jean-michel à l'époque à l'époque
d'abord tu as il est beau gosse
d'accord c'était un journaliste engagé
sérieux pugnace la vieillesse est un
naufrage
l'époque aussi où il est plus beau si
j'étais celib direct d'ailleurs la
soirée ne pas terminer la saison est
finie non comment la saison est finie
qu'est ce que c'est mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive julie mais c'est quoi ce débris
vite et devoirs de vacances
ces listes orthophoniste en fait une
liste orthophoniste john wallace sur
boulogne du palais les prenante d'un
projet d accès juste que c'est un devoir
de vacances tu vas revenir avec une
diction parfaite jean-michel merci
[Applaudissements]
j'aurai la décence de ne pas lire les
noms des médecins c'est maintenait ce
qui nous a conseillé c'est pas ça jean
michel est ce que vraiment julie raynaud
je pense que vous auriez pu faire une
histoire avec elle ça a toujours été ma
came ces rajouts retrouver sublime
intelligent drôle fine et je me suis
toujours très bien entendu avec elle
s'est même j'avoue que ces circonstances
il était prêté j'aurais adoré avoir une
belle et vous faire un petit bisou et
orbi à l'effet de la wii
[Musique]
je voudrais pas avoir à te virer à la
rentrée c'était un jour il faut faire
attention donc ce bisou il est accepté
et me demander où il a si la shlmr non
julie je veux y aller il ya quelqu'un
d'autre qui veut me qu'est ce qu'il
s'était passé libre par exemple mais
pareil dont moi je suis moi je prends
tout ce qui à mon avis faut que je me
dépêche